this phenomenon with tiger woods turn
down live golf
700 million to an 800 million dollar
offer that's the biggest offer they made
to anybody this was in an attempt to
lure the 15 time major winner away from
the pga tour according to liv golf ceo
greg norman the number has been out
there yes norman said tiger is a needle
mover so of course you got to look at
the best of the best they originally
approached tiger before i became ceo so
yes
that number is somewhere in that
neighborhood the saudi arabia back golf
league has grown notorious for offering
audacious sums of money to pride golfers
from pga tour with woods offer being the
most lucrative total known to date so
what do you think about you know why
this has become so controversial you
know oh my god i cannot believe you're
gonna go and take money from you know
saudi arabia why would you do that do
you realize what they do over there what
are your thoughts on this this is my
very first time
hearing anything about this and i'm not
i'm not even familiar with live golf is
what what exactly is live golf oh you're
this is you have no clue this is totally
really
so do you want to kind of tell them
what's going on with lip golf yeah not
that i'm a huge golf guy but basically
they started a competitive uh
league two
or championship series to basically the
pga okay so and now they're basically
let's see who's who can be bought well
phil mickelson can be bought this guy's
gotta have a lot of problems boom let's
buy that guy he's a big name boom here's
a couple hundred million good good good
for you
good and then there's there's names
after names are a big golf guy exactly
okay who can be bought who can be bought
away from the pga the way that i'm
processing this is like
you know what china has done in the nba
why you know lebron takes a lot of heat
and a lot of the nba players but they
don't speak about what's going on in
china and the totalitarian state that's
going on there and the uyghurs that are
forced to do whatever are allegedly that
they have to do
a whole lot of tv money exactly so you
know so basically i think saudi arabia
sort of took the blueprint of what the
uh china has done uh with the nba and
said all right
let's do a little golf league here and
let's see how many players we can
purchase
so live golf it's a saudi company it's a
saudi company okay exactly
and uh
you know players are for hire and uh
tiger woods they said all right he's the
biggest name in golf how much is it
gonna cost to buy tiger and allegedly
that number is gonna be more than 800
million because he said no to that
interesting so when they throw a b on
there is tiger going to say yes he's
going to say no we'll see what happens
but
uh and greg norman the shark right
i think he's what the director of
operations what is he the president and
ceo
yeah okay so
interesting and then obviously there was
a lot of backlash last week at trump's
golf course because they hosted i think
a big live event and you had a lot of
911 um
descendants right advocates basically
saying
all right i mean they they some some
stuff was declassified recently about
saudi arabia and basically their role in
911 and it wasn't pretty for saudi
arabia and then you can throw on top of
that the whole jamal khashoggi thing you
know
you know
blood on the hands what you know how
much can does it cost for you to be
bought i think is the big question here
that's right so i mean how are you
you're a golf guy what's going on yeah
what do you think is going on here with
live golf and tiger so there's a couple
things that are going on uh first of all
the pga tour has always been
heavy-handed whenever you have a
monopoly whether it's the nfl the nba or
major league baseball you always have
these conflicts between players and the
players associations they always
unionize versus
versus the um
so you have the owners and the stadiums
on this hand and then we have the
players associations on this hand and
the tv money goes over here and then
they give them contracts to play well
it's that way in golf too and
the
interesting thing about it is the pga
tour has been kind of heavy-handed
and they've been inconsistent on things
uh dustin johnson was a very very
popular golfer who
uh flunked three drug tests we now know
for using coke and
instead they said he's taking a
six-month leave of absence because he
hurt his back jet skiing
and everybody in the tour was like what
sort of bs is this why can't we just
come out and say he failed the drug test
any drugs or perform enhancing drugs we
don't want them in our sport
including
you know recreational abuse drugs so
there's always been this this thing with
the pga similar the way the nba
sometimes or nfl will suspend this
player not that player you know when
things happen
and uh so it opened the door for a
competitive series and they had big
saudi money behind him and says tell you
what there's no monopoly
um
pga tour players get to play in the
british open the open you know you don't
have to be member of the tour you're
invited to the open you're invited to
the u.s open you're invited to the
masters those are not pga tour events
they're all independent the majors
um except the pga and so
finally the pop boil's over and they're
like well what if we got a bunch of
money and started a competing global
league
and what if we paid people
to come into the league so we could
prime the pump and get some people
know here and that's what's happened big
names right and it happens to be it
comes with saudi arabia and the
underlying social things that people
know about
but that's what's happened they've tried
to compete a competitive league and
they've paid some big um appearance fees
by the way appearance fees have been
around in tennis forever right uh the
joker gets three and a half million
dollars to appear at certain tournaments
um that are not mainstream so here's
about tigers let me just read what tiger
said okay so in other words like to to
really compare
uh uh uh
paul just said something very
interesting he says liv golf is like the
jake paul of the golf world okay so
they're kind of cutting the big checks
is what they're doing okay uh and and
here's a comment from tiger woods i'll
just read it
i said uh at 2022 uh uh uh open
championships he was asked about joining
live
he said i disagree with it
uh i think that they've done uh is
they've turned their back on what has
allowed them to get to this position
i know that the pga tour stands for i
know what the pga tour stands for and
what we have done and what the tour has
given us the ability to chase after our
careers and to earn what we get and the
trophies we have been able to play for
in the history that has been part of
this game
um this is his comments when he turned
down
seven or 800 million dollars tom when
you hear that
knowing tiger what do you think about
tiger saying something like that well i
think
tigers had his own
set of headlines for which he could have
been suspended in many sports
unfortunately um and
tiger is just saying don't bite the hand
that feeds you we don't need change
that's all he's saying that's always
you know you are he's also worth a
billion dollars so it's easy if you're
worth a billion dollars to kind of turn
down however many hundred million and
that is bubba watson's point right and
so if you're if you're only worth a
couple million bucks and you've been
working your ass off your whole life and
you're 48 years old whatever your number
is or you're 35 years old and you're
number 25 in the world you've gotten up
there to that level and they're going to
offer you
a walk across appearance fee of 20
million dollars exactly part of the tour
you look at it and you say wow so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]